il faudrait un petit prime par mois
toujours pas là
alors une Hebdo tu sais quoi j'ai fait
déjà tes preuves dans l'émission
une semaine sur trois semaines
sur trois donc ça fait des doses
bien sûr tu en fais combien 4 par 4 4
par 4 dans la 4 4
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
merci patron
alors moi c'est pour tous mes cam
arades je pense qu'on aimerait tous
parce qu'on en a parlé avoir deux loges
assez septieux pour pouvoir être avant
et après l'émission pour débriefer ou
pour briefer et avec des canapés un peu
confortables avec des fruits frais des
choses un peu light avant l'été
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
jamais rien demandé à personne veut dire
quoi ça oui alors moi je vous demanderai
pas d'argent il y a une rumeur assez
vite qui dit que dans votre loge vous
avez vos propres toilettes privées que
personne les a jamais utilisé à part
vous jamais donc moi mon rêve
ultime c'est de monter sur votre trône
et de poser une pêche dans la Bolivie
[Applaudissements]
oui une revendication stylistique c'est
quoi vous avez basculé cette année et
moi chaque fois que vous arrivez là je
craque souvent pour vos modèles soit de
switcher soit de chemises soit de tout
donc ce que je vous propose c'est une
fois par mois pas plus donc je suis je
reste voilà pas trop exigeante une fois
par mois vous me donnez vous m'offrez
une de vos tenues que j'ai bien aimé pas
mal
on verra on verra mais on n'a pas moins
bien
une fois par mois on va voir on va voir
mais pour l'instant j'ai pas dit non
j'ai pas dit non j'ai pas dit oui j'ai
pas dit non j'ai pas dit oui moi ce que
je pourrais avoir une place de parking
[Applaudissements]
un conteneur ils ont les marionnettes
des Guignols et hors de question
n'est autorisé à rentrer dans l'enceinte
de l'établissement à côté de la vôtre à
côté
d'ailleurs je vais manger en moto ou en
vélo électrique et tout non voilà la
place est libre non c'est au cas
où parce que j'aime bien me balader pour
cette base oui alors vu qu'on a
quasiment tous des week-ends
une fois par mois un week-end chez vous
la plupart du temps mais ça peut être ça
peut être aussi extérieur dans un grand
parc d'attractions
même pas c'est non c'est pour la
cohésion
de groupe je l'ai déglingué c'est
pour la cohésion à Marrakech c'est non
c'est bon allez oui alors moi c'est pas
une revendication liée au travail c'est
un souhait une demande faite à mon
patron donc vous en ce moment on échange
beaucoup on a énormément de points
communs on partage et c'est vrai que
mais weekend sont un peu tristes et
j'aimerais emmener Fatou en weekend en
voiture avec un de vos modèles le plus
modeste soit-il est-ce que ce serait
possible
et en échange je vous laisse mon passe
Navigo pour vous découvrir
avec un plan du métro
il rend pas la bague et en plus il
demande des trucs
[Applaudissements]
t'inquiète pas gilberté t'inquiète pas
je t'en parlerai je t'embrasse
salut
c'est bon
[Applaudissements]
il a dit que vous échangiez énormément
d'accord
on fait la même émission
[Rires]
c'est quoi Fatou ou encore ce week-end
je pense qu'elle sera pas totalement
disponible mais
je regarde la télé j'ai vu que son
rien
non non elle est avec elle va dans le
Perche possiblement une personne
[Rires]
je te dis la vérité
la meuf elle me dit là je suis
célibataire
vous devez en avoir là non non voilà
hypothétiquement une meuf vous dirait
j'attends deux trois ans d'accord
dans trois ans ma meuf me dit je vais
dans le Perche vous me reposer frère
arrête frère si je vais voir une perche
pour me faire déglinguer
[Applaudissements]
pas de réseau là-bas comme ça
sur la tête je suis sûr et certain
qu'elle va dire bah non je captais pas
pour vérifier
je vais me reposer de venir vraiment
dans le Perche oui donc elle a pris le
billet de train et tout non euh ça fait
accompagner en voiture
son ami qui habite dans le Perche qui
vient la chercher après voilà on est
dans le Perche son ami
je connais pas le prénom
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
et tu connais pas le prénom de la de la
vision
elle a paru con mais oui
c'est ça
[Rires]
le ciment du couple c'était la confiance
oui
à mon avis ça va ça va dérouiller non
mais je te dis oui Gilles ça me fait de
la peine tu naïf évidemment que c'est un
énorme mytho mais je te jure je te parle
je te parle franchement là c'est un ami
qui parle vérifier Gilles tu es cocu ma
couille
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
qu'est-ce que tu en penses ce weekend
c'est lui qui l'emmène c'est lui qui
l'emmène en voiture
incroyable franchement non mais je te
jure non mais franchement non mais c'est
donnant étonnant
d'aujourd'hui parce qu'on a quelque
chose il me les a accordé gentiment
s'il vous plaît ne me dites pas non
Cyril